bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france ce boycott n'est pas
une première la stratégie a déjà été
utilisé en 2018 pour la présidentielle
que vise l'opposition avec ce boycott
quelle est la stratégie aujourd'hui de
juan garrido selon vous alors je crois
que s'il n'est pas inintéressant de
faire une petite chronologie pour
expliquer ma présence ici et maintenant
sur votre chaîne il ya quelques jours
elliott abraham donc qui est le criminel
de guerre qui est l'envoyé spécial de
washington pour le venezuela a émis des
déclarations qualifiant de farce les
prochaines gestes des prochaines
élections législatives
en fait monsieur abrams et washington
ont donné le top départ d'une campagne
médiatique et psychologique visant à
discréditer totalement les élections
transparentes et démocratiques qui
auront lieu le 6 décembre prochain et le
un secteur de l'opposition et je crois
que c'est très important de souligner un
secteur minoritaire de l'opposition a
joué son rôle
c'est à dire de ne pas décider de ne pas
participer à des élections dont ils ont
tout fait pour les saboter et notamment
en sabotant complètement la possibilité
d'avoir des deux nouvelles autorités
électorales ce qui était une vieille
rengaine de l'opposition ces lacs dont
la cour suprême qui a dû trancher pour
élire de nouvelles
les autorités électorales et à partir de
cet instant le chronogramme électoral
est en marche
la semaine prochaine il y aura des
audits avec tous les représentants des
partis des 105 partis je répète vous
m'avez bien entendu des 105 partis qui
vont se présenter aux élections du 6
décembre alors les fectivement sans la
participation des 26 ou 27 organisations
que vous avez mentionné vous faites
allusion à l'instant au tribunal suprême
de justice l'opposition rejette à sa
tête la nomination d'une dira alfonso
comme comme président du conseil
national électoral
le psg qui est considéré comme acquis au
pouvoir du président alain d'euros quel
est votre regard là-dessus
non je crois qu'il faut il faut que les
auditeurs comprennent bien que ce
secteur donc minoritaire de l'opposition
qui est qui ce qui s'affiche on va dire
derrière wang wei d'eau je me permets de
vous corriger méprendre rideau n'est
plus président de l'assemblée nationale
du venezuela depuis le 5 janvier dernier
si vous voulez ce secteur ne veut pas
d'élections et pourquoi il ne veut pas
d'élection car ils savent très bien en
tout cas pour la majorité de ces députés
qui ne vont pas être réélu
or le gua ido le projet gouaille de
l'opération guido et le nom la façade ce
dos légale qui va permettre une
spoliation des biens de la république
bolivarienne du venezuela
les personnes les dirigeants des partis
que vous avez mentionné ont besoin de ne
pas aller à des élections et de
maintenir cette façade ce dos légal pour
pouvoir recevoir des dollars pour
pouvoir être finalement payé reçoit d
une contrepartie financière et les
grandes puissances occidentales états
unis en tête mais aussi européennes ont
aussi besoin de cette façade pour
pouvoir spolier les biens de la nation
l'énergie éolienne et 7 face à l'
s'écroulerait s'il y avait six une
participation de toute l'opposition à
ces élections c'est la seule raison pour
laquelle les états unis l'europe et
roanne guido et ses comparses essaie de
jeter le discrédit sur un processus qui
je le répète n'a pas changé ou très peu
depuis 20 ans qui est absolument
transparent démocratique qui fut reconnu
comme le meilleur système électoral au
monde par l'ancien président des états
unis jimmy carter et mamadou est ce que
vous n'avez pas le sentiment que
l'élection prévue donc le 6 décembre
prochain risque d'aggraver
un peu plus la fracture entre deux
groupes politiques qui se disputent le
pouvoir aux rideaux d'un côté et nicolás
maduro de l'autre on a bien compris
non pas du tout pas du tout parce que la
halle alors déjà le la fracture
évidemment c'est ce sont les
vénézuéliens qui vivent la situation une
situation délicate due au blocus
criminel des états unis est due aussi à
la demande de plus de mesure de
coercitives unilatérales de la part du
clan de guido donc en fait les
vénézuéliens se sont complètement
détourné de ce clan de guido qui est
finalement une entreprise mafieuse qui a
généré un réseau de corruption
gigantesque lévénez elven le savent les
vénézuéliens lui reprocher de corruption
les vénézuéliens lui reproche aussi
d'avoir demandé l'application de
sanctions qu'ils vivent au jour le jour
et on a pu voir décision énorme y
compris au sein des principaux partis
d'opposition
des militants ont demandé à ce qui est
des élections internes pour pouvoir
écarter deux des élites politiques des
partis de certains partis d'opposition
pour pouvoir retrouver le chemin de la
normalité politique démocratique
merci d'avoir pris le temps de répondre
à nos question rom amigos journaliste
fondateur du site francophone
d'actualité de l'amérique latine
les deux rives